aujourd'hui vendredi 10 avril 2015
nouveau journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 et dans l'actualité yvelinoise
aujourd'hui dernier conseil municipal
pour henri paillet le maire ump de
coignières va tenir ce soir sa dernière
assemblée dédié au budget il annoncera
ensuite sa démission et samedi matin la
ville aura un nouveau première édile un
fab lab comprenez ateliers de
fabrication numérique ouvre ses portes
au public à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
explications avec ses responsables tout
à l'heure en plateau et puis en seconde
partie de ce journal nous reviendrons
sur l'essentiel de l'actualité de la
semaine fermeture du centre nautique de
maurepas retour à l'autonomie financière
pour l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines et les projets de la sncf pour
lignes du transilien
les impôts locaux vont augmenter après
les baisses de dotations de l'état aux
communes ces dernières présentent en ce
moment à des budgets forcément contraint
ainsi à elancourt le taux communal de la
taxe d'habitation 2015 passera de 13,39
à 14,46 % et de 18,36 à
19,83 pour le foncier bâti l'opposition
ps parle de trahison du maire envers les
électeurs ce dernier évoque la gestion
calamiteuse de l'état et puis à magny
les hameaux même situation mais cette
fois ci la majorité socialiste a voté
l'augmentation la taxe foncière est
aujourd'hui à près de 22 % la taxe
d'habitation à 11,8 pour cent
l'opposition ump de monde de son côté
est des efforts de gestion le vote du
budget à coignières ce sera aussi
vendredi soir mais ce conseil municipal
aura une saveur toute particulière pour
le maire à la tête de la commune depuis
1986 henry pe a décidé de démissionner
un ras-le-bol général de la politique
catherine mulato revient sur ce choix
inattendu samedi 11 avril dernier
conseil municipal pour henri pailleux
celui qui a cumulé six mandats à la tête
de la commune de coignières a décidé de
jeter l'épongé
l'intégration de sa ville en janvier
prochain à l'intercommunalité de saint
quentin en yvelines et le projet de 12
rayés du schéma directeur de la région
ile-de-france ont fini par le convaincre
de quitter son fauteuil
il s'en était expliqué en février
dernier lors d'une séance de dédicace de
son ouvrage la force de la conviction
dans le monde tel qu'il évolue et la
france telle qu'elle évolue je suis
désolé de le dire il ya plus d'éthique
il ya plus de morale ni n'y a que
l'intérêt particulier par le passé
l'intérêt général et ça pour moi c'est
absolument insupportable
je suis en rupture totale avec je dirais
ce qui va et renseigné par mes parents
par les jésuites parce que j'ai passé 10
ans chez eux ses débuts mais ils m'ont
adressé quand il fallait et donc je suis
arrivé à prendre est pur il laisse donc
la mairie un an après avoir été réélu ce
samedi les conseillers se retrouveront
pour voter le budget à l'issue de
l'ordre du jour henri pailleux remettra
sa démission
s'en suivra ensuite l'élection du
nouveau maire seul un vote en conseil
municipal suffit si lé nom de celui qui
prendra les rênes de la commune n'est
pas connue il se murmure que c'est son
adjoint aux affaires économiques jean
pierre sevestre qui pourrait reprendre
le flambeau l'économie une priorité pour
la commune qui ne compte que 4417
habitants mais de nombreux surfaces
commerciales 800 enseignes employant
plus de 6000 salariés à 10h30 ce samedi
la salle du conseil municipal de
coignard sera très certainement bien
remplie pour assister au départ d'henri
bayeux et à cette nouvelle page qui
s'ouvre pour l'histoire de la commune
nous allons laisser la politique de côté
à présent pour évoquer les fab lab à ces
ateliers de fabrication numérique
participatif et citoyens qui ont
actuellement le vent en poupe et 50 ans
va dorénavant avoir le sien invités pour
en parler à mes les aubert bonjour du
gymnase est chargée de projet
communications la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin et
arnaud sauser bonjour aussi vous êtes
membre du skylab du skylab pardon vais y
arriver pour débuter si on peut
expliquer à quoi sert un fab labs
justement alors un fab lab c'est un lieu
où on va mettre à disposition des
machines des outils
numériques des ordinateurs pour réaliser
des objets donc les fab lab sont
destinés à la population et les ateliers
de fabrication numérique plus pour les
universités ou les entreprises mais nous
on a vraiment une vocation à ouvrir à la
population elles permettent aux gens de
réaliser les choses commencent à bouger
actionnaires concrètement aujourd'hui on
est on a créé l'association en décembre
donc on est à la recherche d'un local
pour commencer mais on a déjà constitué
une communauté de 120 personnes où on se
réunit pratiquement très régulièrement
pour faire avancer ce projet et on
cherche des locaux sur la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines montigny
préférence mais pourquoi pas et on
voudrait pouvoir s'installer preuves
rapidement on a déjà répondu à un appel
à projet pour un financement d'une
partie du matériel auprès la région donc
on attend cette réponse donc le projet
vraiment au bout tout début et on espère
qu'on va pouvoir démarrer rapidement et
qu'en pense la communauté
d'agglomération alors de ce projet alors
le projet en fait c'est surtout le fab
lab les termes de fab lab qui est très
intéressant donc nous allah on a choisi
en fait de proposer une exposition à la
maison de l'environnement des sciences
et du développement durable le rôle de
la communauté agglomération c'est
surtout de renseigner les saint
quentinois sur ce qu'est ce que peut
offrir un fab lab les potentiels énormes
et du coup via la maison d'environnement
en ce moment il ya une exposition qui
permet justement de comprendre ce qu'on
peut il trouver dans un fab lab on a des
machines outils donc une imprimante 3d
en démonstration on a également des
petits ateliers de bidouille de
bricolage de couture parce qu'un fab lab
c'est aussi l'occasion d'apprendre à
faire soi-même à réparer à créer et à
concevoir des objets que ce soit des
objets du quotidien voire même pourquoi
pas en termes industriels si on a des
idées de d'innovation voilà c'est
vraiment en tout cas permettre de
renseigner d'informer de sensibiliser
les saint-quentinoises sur ce qu'est un
fab lab et du coup la potence enfin le
potentiel fablab de 50 minutes qu'on
fait des citoyens actifs exagrid
humblement c'est le but c'est de fédérer
aussi enfin le but c'est aussi ses
traits inscrit sur le territoire
damphousse à répondre aux besoins des
gens donc c'est pour ça qu'on se
construit avec eux avec des gens qui ont
envie de bricoler comme pas forcément
les outils chez eux avec des personnes
qu'ils sont
aux passionnés donc ils veulent partager
la passion dont ils vont un peu animée
le fab lab le lieu lui-même et après on
a les experts qui là sont vraiment des
gens qui qui son point de vue dans un
domaine qui ont une passion et qui qui
veulent effectivement la partager
accompagner des projets donc le skylab a
aussi une vocation échos fable c'est ce
que la connotation qu'on a donc ces
écossais effectivement les
préoccupations environnementales on va
essayer de porter les projets qui sont
avec ses préoccupations
environnementales pour préparer aussi la
coop 21 de décembre est aussi eko eko
dans le terme d'économie circulaire donc
récupération de matériaux donc on a
vocation à essayer de récupérer des
matériaux des entreprises du secteur
bois carton pourquoi c'est une
matériauthèque et permettent aux ans au
personnes de réaliser des objets des
meubles des landes et voilà deux d'être
un peu denses ont évoqué les entreprises
justement le but c'est aussi voilà
d'impliquer citoyens entreprises
artisans associations aussi vous faites
un endroit 3 on 3 6 blancs comme on dit
quand on fait des
études de marché on a donc les habitants
donc les trois qataris gdi de simples
bricoleur l'expert et on a le monde
éducatif où on espère aussi pouvoir
capter tous les enseignants qui n'ont
pas forcément aujourd'hui le temps de se
former sur ces sujets là et pourtant
c'est un sujet qui la prend de plus en
plus de place dans le monde de
l'éducation donc leur permettre de
revenir dans nos locaux est aussi allé
chez eux et on a aussi un volet qui
serait sur les entreprises alors les
entreprises ont là encore découpé en
deux parties les petites entreprises et
les grandes entreprises les petites
entreprises ça peut être le designer le
l'artisan ou qui a besoin de réaliser un
prototype pour valider une idée un
concept qui est là et après sur les
grandes entreprises ne visent plutôt sur
des stages de motivation d'université de
à l'innovation sur sur une équipe
professionnellement vous avez évoqué
l'exposition qui a lieu en ce moment il
ya un rendez vous 1 demain la maison de
l'environnement 11 avril à partir de 10
heures il y aura un meetups à sa fin une
réunion et puis et puis ensuite des
ateliers comment ça va se passer demain
alors demain c'est une journée chargée
effectivement donc la deezer
effectivement un open coffee c'est à
dire c'est l'occasion pour les
associations de présenter son projet aux
membres de l'association de ceux qui
savent déjà qu'ils sont peut-être un peu
sensibilisés mais aussi de l'ouvrir à
d'autres personnes qui s'interrogent et
qui se demande justement ce que c'est
donc ça c'est vraiment une réunion de
rencontres de débats des changes et
c'est aussi l'occasion de savoir un peu
les attentes des saint quentinois aussi
sur l'ouverture d'un fable sommes
d'ailleurs l'association a lancé aussi
un questionnaire pourra on peut recenser
les envies les besoins et à peut-être
adapter le fable en fonction de ça aussi
c'est un site internet un style à boire
ça va s'afficher si vous n'avez pas le
temps de noter skylab point org ce
rendez vous demain particulièrement
important pour fédérer un peu plus de
monde en fait l'on réalisé ces rendez
vous donnés dans les lieux publics une
fois c'était aux marinas une fois
c'était dans l'espace bébé libre de
coworking pour l'instant on essaye
d'être dans coeur de la ville et que les
gens viennent nous rencontrer pour bien
coller à leurs besoins leurs attentes et
vienne demandent justement quasi elle
demande à chaque fois on a on a une
vingtaine de personnes qui viennent
comme ça spontanément alors que pour
l'instant c'est une information qui
circule via la maison de l'environnement
bien sûr mais sur le site internet meet
up on a créé un open qu'aussi saint
quentin en yvelines sur cette thématique
là et donc les gens aujourd'hui c'est
les gens qui vont sur cette plateforme
là qu'ils ont l'habitude qui viennent
mais dès que le roger sera un peu mieux
connu on pense que c'est immonde aura
beaucoup plus de monde et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tout de suite dès
dès les dix premières minutes les gens
s'impliquent nous on a quelque chose qui
est assez interactif où on leur demande
de participer on est la dernière réunion
on a choisi des projets sur la une lampe
un éclairage intelligent ou des
réalisations d'objets modélisme avec du
hard ou hinault donc ça on a déjà défini
ce projet là avec des méthodes
de participatif des gens c'est qu'on
peut pas guider les gens sur un projet
ou un autre on veut vraiment qu'ils se
l'approprient et ça ça fonctionne très
très bien tout ça sur le mode
participatif les gens ne payent pas pour
y participer commencent à se financer
skylab pour l'instant où mais sur nous
on a une association qui s'appelle
athlète qui est pour le développement
des fablabs dans l'ouest parisien dont
il ya deux projets il y en a un sur
versailles est un sou
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc
l'adhésion est à 35 euros pour l'instant
permettra d'accéder au dos de lieu quand
ils auront tenu des lieux auprès des
communes et donc à partir de là on va
décliner un mode de fonctionnement déjà
dans un premier temps pour les habitants
disons club avec réalisation d'objets et
après on a déjà un business model pour
des activités comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure sur des formations sur des
modules d'accompagnement de pour le
monde éducatif et pour les entreprises
donc là on va essayer de fictivement de
de dépendre on va dépendre des bus de
subventions c'est pour ça qu'on est loin
des appels à projets de la région par
exemple mais on essaye déjà de
d'anticiper une évolution assez rapide
pour avoir en équilibre financier il ya
ce rendez vous de demain si vous voulez
en savoir plus après pour la maison de
l'environnement là l'exposition va se
poursuivre encore jusqu'au 25 avril à
les accompagner complété par des
ateliers justement pour les enfants donc
un atelier de couture pendant les
vacances scolaires un atelier de
bricolage demain après midi justement on
initie également les enfants à la
programmation avec des cartes ar oui
nous donc on apprend aux enfants à
donner vie à des objets à programmer
l'allumage d'une lampe et ça marche très
très bien et complète pour s'y
impliquent oui c'est tout à fait mais
c'est justement et c'est aussi la
volonté aussi des parents de donner
l'occasion aux enfants de savoir
eux-mêmes fabrique un objet ça je crois
qu'il est aussi un fort intérêt là
dessus merci à tous les deux d'être venu
nous parler de ce projet rendez vous
donc demain à la maison de
l'environnement et puis sur le site
internet et skylab point org merci à
vous la suite du journal c'est avec de
la culture le championnat intercollèges
d'improvisation toujours créé et porté
par déclic théâtre a permis hier de
dégager les demi-finalistes 2015 c'était
au prisme elle encourt donc le reportage
de yolaine torres sur des images
d'elodie -
le carrefour d oublier
nombre de joueurs est limité
catégorie libre la mobilisation
les dés sont jetés il faut maintenant
improvisé hier au prisme d'elancourt dix
établissements s'affronter pour la 16e
édition du championnat intercollèges de
match d'improvisation théâtrale de saint
quentin en yvelines un événement
organisé par la compagnie déclic théâtre
il ya d'abord une notion de partage de
rencontre c'est à dire qu'évidemment là
on a affaire à des jeunes collégiens qui
ne se connaissent pas du tout qui ne se
sont jamais vus donc il faut oser voilà
passé le briser la glace à les
rencontrer des gens qu'on connaît pas
que sont pas de notre collège compas
notre quartier qui n'ont pas notre ville
après évidemment faut une grande liberté
un peu de folie certainement et puis on
se rend compte quand même qu'il ya le
caractère compte la nature même des des
comédiens fin des comédiens en herbe
compte aussi vachement à chaque match et
le public de la salle au vote pour son
préféré mais les voix prépondérante sont
celles du jury composé de dix élèves
représentatif de tous les collèges
les étoiles ont également été décernés à
ceux qui se sont démarqués ça veut dire
qu'on a du potentiel mais pour moi j'en
ai pas plus que les autres on a tous été
bon et voilà comment une étoile ben
c'est ce qui se sont plus démarqué ce
qui sont données le plus donc après ça
me fait plaisir parce que ils ont vu que
je me suis donné pour le match en fait
c'est ça s'est décerné par saint astier
par un manque de des cleantech est quand
même beaucoup d'expérience du coup ça
c'est comme un trophée
ça veut dire qu la poule à
sur les dix quatre collèges se sont
qualifiés le collège le village et le
collège courbet de trappes le collège
einstein de manigat mois ci que le
collège du mas del en cours tout ce
rendez vous pour la donne et finale le
12 juin la mairie à trappes
nous en venons à présent à l'essentiel
de la semaine avec l'annoncé mardi de la
fermeture du centre nautique de maurepas
fermeture en urgence de lourds travaux
qui doivent être réalisés la situation
était pourtant connue depuis des années
le reportage de mélanie poquet et de
william
les portes sont closes depuis vendredi
dernier pour des raisons de sécurité
grégory gary astier maire de maurepas a
pris un arrêté municipal après la prise
de connaissance il ya quelques mois d'un
audit réalisé en 2009 les dangers se
situe notamment aux faux plafonds et
également sur la charpente elle même
alors le faux plafond les fixations sont
totalement endommagées et corrodé donc
il ya un risque de chute sur le public
et sur la structure elle même on est au
delà de la corrosion maximum il y avait
déjà eu la chute d'un élément du faux
plafond
bien avant en 2006 ou 2007 je crois bien
à la suite de sa fille l'a été installés
pour protéger le public mais une plaque
du faux plafond est également cette fois
ci tombait il y un peu plus d'un an
selon un audit complémentaire demandée
par la municipalité actuelle les travaux
s'évaluerait à deux milliards d'euros
pour la charpente seulement le centre
nautique accueille plus de 170 mille
utilisateurs par an dont 40 mille
scolaires qui viennent de maurepas et
l'encours et coignières datant de plus
de 40 ans la structure n'a jamais été
rénové là on est dans une mesure
d'urgence tous les scénarios sont
envisageables
fermeture définitive destruction
reconstruction réaménagement de celle ci
pour le moment on n'en est pas là mais
en tout cas ma volonté de mer c'est
d'avoir un centre nautique sur la vie de
maurepas en attendant qu'une décision
soit prise la commune va étudier
diverses solutions pour organiser la
répartition des usagers sur les piscines
alentours la fermeture d'urgence dural
jusqu'au 3 mai prochain
la fermeture d'urgence décidée jusqu'à
la fin du mois d'avril mais difficile au
regard des travaux à engager d'imaginer
une réouverture prochainement c'est ce
qu'a expliqué confirmé cette semaine le
maire sur ce plateau écoutez il faut pas
se le cacher l'avenir est sombre pour
cette structure d'autant plus qu' il y a
une relation affective avec la piscine à
maurepas j ai moi même appris à nager
j'ai grandi et maurepas et donc
évidemment c'est dans la douleur que
j'ai annoncé sa mort passe bien mais je
garantis leur sécurité est évidemment
une fois que l'audit sera rendue tous
les scénarios sont envisageables mais je
le dis et je le redis je souhaite une
piscine à maurepas il ya des fonds
aujourd'hui qui peuvent être débloqués
par la ville déjà pour faire des travaux
en fonction de ce que dira le deuxième
audit alors il ya des fonds oui et non
tout va dépendre des sa santé c'est
important oui complètement d'autant plus
que là on est plus à 700000 euros mais
si c'est les travaux seulement sur la
couverture et le faux plafond on est à
plus de 2 millions d'euros 2 millions
d'euros ce n'est pas rien dans la
situation financière actuelle après il
faudra a mandaté un cabinet d'experts
qui pourra nous dire s'il faut
réhabiliter totalement cette structure
ou détruire et reconstruire et là c'est
une autre affaire autre invité cette
semaine du journal le président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette dernière
vient tout juste de retrouver son
autonomie
financière placé sous tutelle du
rectorat et donc de l'état en raison
d'importants déficits elle est à nouveau
libre de voter son budget jean henric
vestiaire est revenu sur les efforts
qu'il a fallu faire ces derniers mois je
précise n'y a pas eu de licenciement et
le non renouvellement de contrats pour
les contractuels simplement donc des
emplois de fonctionnaires vacants sont
restés vacants il des contractuels qui
ont pu partir ailleurs on n'avait pas
remplacé voilà comment c'est fait la
réduction du nombre d'emplois car ce que
sur deux trois ans on arrêtera luan
centaines d'emplois qui ont été
supprimés sur 1600 sur 1727 significatif
parce sur l'emploi voilà après donc une
partie une autre partie importante sur
le fonctionnement c'est à dire d'une
part on a réduit comme vous disais et
dotations de fonctionnement aux
laboratoires aux iut aux ufr aux
facultés comme vous voulez donc lors de
deux trois quarts par rapport à ce qui
était demandé - ou à peu près par
rapport à 2013 donc c'était assez fun
assez sévère sur les recettes d'état
parce que le nombre de composantes ont
des ressources qu'on appelle propre
parce qu'il pratique de l'apprentissage
la france continue dont il arrive à
avoir des financements par ailleurs donc
sur la nature de la composante c'était
plus ou moins douloureux vous récupérez
votre autonomie financière concrètement
ça signifie quoi vous allez pouvoir
justement lancé à des projets vous
tourner vers la mine et non c'était
c'est à dire qu'on a beaucoup plus de
souplesse pas alors que l'année dernière
il ya eu en 2014 à lui à un budget
arrêté par le recteur et n'apportant
arrêté par recteur avec l'accord de
bercy pour faire simple fin mars dans la
douleur
les larmes sueur comme on dit et on a pu
faire qu'une modification fin octobre
voilà donc parlante 2015 c'était plus un
pour la popularité le recteur l'arrêté
phanères en décembre 2014 mais déjà la
semaine dernière on a fait un budget
rectificatif
donc ça on peut régulièrement faire des
budgets rectificatifs
informé le recteur merci pour ça pour un
nouveau simple mais c'est nous qui
sommes est ce conseil d'admistration qui
décide qui votent nous continuons ce
retour sur l'actualité de la semaine et
du côté de la sncf on a dévoilé mercredi
les projets concernant les différentes
lignes du transilien résumé de ce qui
attend les usagers
avec mélanie poker autorisés william
bell
retards à répétition ram saturé
infrastructures obsolètes
le transilien yvelinois est dans la
ligne de mire des usagers conscient des
difficultés transilien sncf a engagé des
études et discussions pour analyser ces
difficultés notamment sur la lune elle
avec le tronçons paris versailles
il ya deux problèmes aujourd'hui un la
ligne est saturé c'est à dire que alors
qu'elle fonctionnait très bien il ya
quelques années le fait qu'il est de
plus en plus de voyageurs fait que les
temps d'attentes hangar montée décembre
sont de plus en plus en plus important
et donc un effet boule de neige les
trains prennent de pin pilote en
collaboration avec l'association plus de
train pour la défense transilien à
élaborer un nouveau plan de transport
comprenant une meilleure répartition des
trains il sera mis en oeuvre le 13
décembre de cette année autre sujet
d'amélioration la ligne du rer c pour
laquelle plus d'un milliard d'euros de
travaux sont engagés jusqu'en 2020 cette
ligne souffre particulièrement de
l'ancienneté de ses infrastructures
la ligne c est là l infrastructure
extrêmement ancienne là une caténaire
qui a plus de 95 ans et donc il faut la
rénover il faut rénover également les
rails dans le tronçon central et ce sont
les travaux qu'on engage à partir de
dernière annonce qui concerne aussi les
yvelinois le forfait tout voté en
décembre 2014 avec un tarif unique 2 70
euros il entrera en vigueur le 1er
septembre prochain
transport toujours avec le bilan de la
première année d'activité de bd comme vd
qom qui regroupe chercheurs grandes
entreprises de l'automobile pme et qui
travaillent sur le véhicule de demain
catherine mulato patrick jacques de
dixmude ont assisté à cette cérémonie du
1er anniversaire
cette voiture électrique conduite par
anne charlotte nico a une particularité
elle peut aussi se conduire sans
chauffeur un véhicule totalement
automatisées bourré de capteurs qui
prennent tout en charge à la place du
conducteur un peu à l'image d'un être
humain la voiture conduire a besoin de
percevoir son environnement où sont les
capteurs de perception qui vous seront
là donc celle ci a une vision à 360
degrés afin de limiter le risque dans le
mans voire même supprimer complètement
elle a besoin également de se localiser
donc ce sont le but des capteurs de
localisation puisque vous avez besoin de
savoir où vous êtes et qu elle l
environnement autour de vous et enfin
elle doit prendre des décisions ce qu'on
appelle le module de supervision sont
quittes l'intelligence embarquée et tout
le coeur de nos algorithmes ce véhicule
prototype est l'une des grande fierté de
bd comme il est testé sur les pistes de
satory institut de transition
énergétique a été lancé il ya un an il
travaille sur toutes les questions de
mobilité d'électrification
d'automatisation et de connectivité des
voitures du futur on a les grandes
entreprises de l'automobile française
qui son fondateur de dvd comme des
grands instituts de recherche et puis
également des pme et bientôt des
start-up donc c'est un écosystème de
près de 40 membres qui travaillent
ensemble tous les jours un mariage entre
secteurs public et privé entre petites
et grandes entreprises entre chercheurs
et ingénieurs qui porte ses fruits
aujourd'hui institut emploie un peu
moins de 100 personnes ils seront plus
de 150 à la fin de l'année et il est
prévu encore une centaine n'embauche
d'ici 2016 pour fonctionner vd com qui
fait partie du pays a le plan
d'investissements d'avenir dispose d'un
budget de 19 millions d'euros ce budget
est en croissance donc sur trois ans et
l'ensemble des bd comme est financé à 10
ans pour
bleu baelemans une centaine de millions
d'euros quand l'état met un les
industriels mettent 1 ça c'est le
principe de base du financement de bd
comme reste une interrogation à quand
une voiture sans conducteur sur route
pour l'heure c'est interdit en france et
en europe seul l'état du nevada aux
états unis a donné cette autorisation
pour la google car mais l'avenir
s'annonce radieux pour vd comme en
octobre prochain la ville de bordeaux va
accueillir le congrès mondial des
systèmes automatisés et les responsables
en sont persuadés les derniers levier
législatif devrait se lever en attendant
vd comme travaille également sur un pôle
d'excellence qui ouvrira la fin de
l'année à satory pour préparer cette
fois les moteurs électriques de demain
on se retrouve lundi pour un nouveau
journal l on parlera notamment de
l'élection municipale de dimanche à
voisins le bretonneux excellent week end
sur notre antenne